they can't exclusive everything you've
had a crazy you're doing the summer 1975
or hot 97 suffragette and festival stage
yeah and you've got that call man that's
like I know it's not the main stage but
it's still summer jam the West Coast
artists you know what I'm saying how did
that feel to get that call
I actually like saw it on her neck I
were sound like it was crass saw like a
rumor that I was gonna be I thought I
was elected we're in many stages you
said I just think it's good like you
summer Jim oh I did he's like yeah I
have to [__] Summer Jam tweeted somebody
on the stage that's dope this is a lot
of people come to this capacity it's a
blessing for me because if you look
after some of the names that cake those
are like somebody bleep people just come
and be like you know I can't drink big
yeah of course I mean for me to just be
let's order to ask you about I know you
call yourself
Elly's Guinea puffy at least puffy sorry
pre-pre didn't okay so you're a nice
puffy what where does that stem from
what makes yourself come up with that
alias you could still give me you
haven't heard too many big artists like
you know just great kinda just killed it
like that
what it's like you know I mean not to
take away for them for nobody but you
ever sing about you like really really
coming killi killi from his nobody still
I hate not like that like not fans of
[__] I just have when people ever you
know knowing it's okay sometimes you
gotta be man I'm not really sometimes
you just gotta keep it real
yeah never cool to be a so sometimes you
got a better person no bro chill out
yeah that's not gonna touch me
you know like listening some like
everybody in you know a teeny Kim j-rock
is not even more traditional West Coast
sound to do Kendrick is that is only
flow these guys or style you you're kind
of like I think you're you're you're
you're like you said when you talk when
I when I found out you were at ladies
did you that's what you're calling
yourself or Ella's puffy I kind of took
it like you're kind of like the more
ignorant due to the group as far as
musically but you really you know you'd
be wiling out at home about other [__]
besides a more conscious type of stuff
you know how was it man like fitting in
into that that niche in in the clique
because there's so many different styles
and the black keep it clicking teen will
click doing it we all know that we got
to play our road know your role
you can't have probably still be rapid
about the same [__] kids you grab
it.about me Kendrick pop first go to
future yeah autos then I can't I can't
rap about weekends you rap about because
it's the first off that's not my life
you're gonna be in there's no there's no
businesses vision I'm saying but faster
I mean I just play my bro
it just happens to be that we all plan a
row we don't really think like a lot of
rappers just type in it you know they're
all sound may be on the same label wrong
we know just do I know I'm you you you
know we're talking about Mackendrick
kind of kind of being that I wouldn't
necessarily say entitle you come I do
records would be on stage yeah what's it
been like man like the last eight nine
months just being out doing their own
thing having people know your music you
know what I'm saying you're you're
you're really taking off just without
you know a lot of times like you said
you got that one dude that pops in your
face and it's a lot harder for everybody
else to kind of get out that shadow but
you've done such a good job with that
but it's almost like I don't see an
artist [__] already so it's like what
kind of like I'm not over it I still
love doing cuz you know it's challenging
right now being that will go from
actually helping to make the crowd go a
little better to do that yeah you know
what I mean to be doing it but it's a
blessing man Kendrick helped me to get
to where I am today
like a lot of people he gave me a good
look like you know what I mean I
appreciate him let me be
because I've seen a lot of faces because
a lot of face to see me every night he
bring me a schoolboy q just saying that
it does a lot for putting me on the
right song he's like any old one as big
as Michael Jordan from spiteful chat not
being six foot seven freestyle which is
to give me classic versus bless just for
him to let me do that and plumie helped
me get into this position
hey talk about a little bit your history
with Tiger I know you and I go kind of
back yeah oh I like that was all over TV
okay I know you um you you had stopped
sipping olena yeah have you have you
been able to like keep up staying off
with that yeah yeah cheetah though she
fell off the wagon for a second no I'm
not like that but I got taking like how
to cut or something yeah that's it but
it just didn't do it for me so that's uh
yeah man you know that's what's up man
having some contradiction this is the
album it's so crazy cuz fighting
everybody on TV you guys got albums but
then you know there's the debut album
that everyone you know like like it's
like kind of like in this this landscape
the music those guys like Kendrick they
create yourself putting out albums they
still I considered house really your
debut album now you got the Interscope
situation worked out how far how far on
all that you in recording it
40% 40% almost that I got I switched it
up like twice already concept stuff like
that cuz you know you hear a project for
a regular studio working then I hear
some kids you can play me like most of
his own did it change
because it's not as hard as hard as that
way you know what I'm saying it's a
friendly competition yeah like that it's
so disruptive crazy person whether the
project ya know same period yeah so I
got wrapped a few songs and I can't
start now um you the first two albums
happens in contradiction is the prequel
to the setback and I hear that the new
album is going to fit into the same it's
just worried about actually I'm actually
gonna really really give you to them so
okay and I was still in just a lot of
stuff myself
I mean and actually transforming myself
to a man being raised by is there any
features that you can let off the bag on
the house on my I'm sure I'm not big on
futures you know so I sure like you know
keep it man yeah yeah of course the
founder you'd be lucky if you see
somebody even on the house but but I'm
not taking no money saying I'm not going
to be doing the future features you and
I mean
whereas right now mama I said I'm just
focus on TV if I hear something and I
want somebody on it it was like somebody
mandate that you want to you want to
link up with musically that might you
know surprise people now gonna make
sense that become I like a lot of
artists musically it's got to make sense
in or their busy making sure that
commercial not even like that I'm just
saying like yeah sometimes I feel like
like features should come now for
another thing I wanted to talk to you
about with your live show me I know
Kendrick Lamar's amazing live performer
how much you know have you learned from
him that you apply that he's doing is
your overall a live performance like
like you know how do you describe your
show being more being cuffed
it's like a separate art form in yeah
exactly some Luda master
hey who were some of your influences
coming up I know you from LA so I know
that you know that finally the usuals
you know that Els part is to say East
Coast more Don Wilson East Coast hip-hop
do away with not to be in this house MC
wise yeah DMX somebody who I feel like
doesn't get mentioned as much as you
should its first two out because that
bad rep so people don't want to say but
didn't put a lot of passion in this
music
he made it cool to just say whatever on
the track like [__] barking on the
track
bring in all that [__] you know I mean
like yeah you made everything cool of
course you know the normal stuff yeah as
diligent corrupt man well [__] that's
one everything that the Interscope
situation seems like it's real
beautifully that the record is getting
live on the radio now
which is uh it's crazy I remember when
we first started playing here in Vegas
in rotation I was like like I'm saying
so man much much success to you brother
when this is your time timeframe as far
as getting up debut the debut album out
on Interscope they're not rushing me
right now they may be with the rush but
I mean I just mean just concerned about
getting mustang with writing lined up
right now deal we go see where they're
going
do you feel like when you make a song do
you go in getting in my car like like
music it's not like record I think when
people force the radio [__] they're
always here it's gonna happen it's gonna
happen
you can turn this beat there's not even
a sound into this is all about I just
thought about you know much about but I
appreciate you man come on head on my
record to schoolboy q bootleg care if
you know what it is